If you ever want to feel what it's like to be like three again,
make your thumb, wrestle your pinkie, your pinkies, like.
You have no power in the pink, your pinky. So weak.
That's what it's like to be like a three-year-old straining against your older
brother. That's me get off me.
You got a pinky. That's right. This is what a little digit.
What does that thing get used for? Don't you like?
I hurt my pinky doing that wrestling with my thumb.
Like legitimately it hurts now so weak, but I do so much with my.
Chin ups. There's some reason for it.
So many kettlebell grips. And it's mostly these other fingers.
Even when you draw back a bow, my release doesn't even have a pinky thing.
I draw back with these fingers. His just hangs around for the ride.
You're so mean to your pinkie. Why do you do that?
It's weird how weak it is compared to all the other digits.
Pinky. It's a, it is a very like, you know.
We'll you up with this finger. This finger right here is strong as.
This finger gets a hold of. This is a strong finger. This is a finger.
This not hurting anybody we got on the same hand.
Listen, everyone belongs in the hand like we have.
If you were as strong, physically as your small toe. Wow,
that's great. That's life. Just, everything can you up.
Every pebble is murderous.
Every jumping off stairs to Broadway, you stub your toe. You want to die,
but your little baby toe has zero power.
Grab your little baby toe and like wrestle with it quick.
It has nothing to mess. It's a baby. Yeah.
Babies are stronger than your baby toe. Yeah. Well that's a.
Yeah, that would,
that's the funny thing about the human sentience projection and the time it's
like, we're probably like the little toe of the universe.